E aí
[Música]
é muito boa tarde a todos durante esta
pandemia vivemos várias intermitências
pensamos nas vacinas por exemplo o
quando estão a demorar a chegar alguns
países do mundo e isto acredito e
levou-me a pensar que é porque os
verdadeiros critérios os verdadeiros
valores não comandam esta máquina que
faz funcionar a economia e essa máquina
é o dinheiro é os custos é o lucro é a
poupança
desejamos nós quando compramos coisas e
quando vendemos não
nós temos sempre alguns valores nulos e
levam a fazer olhamos para os critérios
de compra e todos nós nos podemos Rever
aqui nestes critérios muitos produtos
que compramos é pela pressão Social pela
empatia pela reciprocidade e pelo status
que ter alguma coisa nos dá pela
inovação pelo valor mas aqui duas ideias
que quase todo mundo especialmente
aqueles aquelas pessoas que têm menos
capacidades económicas levam em conta
como valor principal são as necessidades
básicas e é o preço o baixo preço um
orçamento com que tem que lidar que é
limitado muitas vezes para a maioria das
pessoas no mundo muito limitado e
portanto quando compram algo não podem
olhar a ética a ser biológico a
qualidade tem que e aquilo de que
necessitam pelo menor custo e o menor
preço possível as empresas que vendem
produtos também tem essa questão e isso
isso muitas vezes são os critérios de
venda
nos critérios de venda as empresas
pensam em uma ideia Global o custo de
produção aquilo que custa produzir um
bem pois tem nesses cursos outros
valores o marketing o transporte a parte
logística dos produtos aquilo que é
quantidade que conseguem produzir e
nessa grande quantidade também diluir os
próprios custos a parte dos impostos o
embalamento dos produtos Quando vamos ao
supermercado os produtos normalmente
estão sempre embalados E isso também
custa a também a extração da
matéria-prima EA transformação o preço
da matéria-prima tudo aquilo que nós
compramos e usamos veio do planeta terra
e foi transformado para nosso usufruto o
custo de produção é diminuído ao máximo
para que depois da variável lucro seja
também aumentada ao máximo e estas
regras são aquelas que fazem o mundo
andar ovais custo a poupança de quem
consome o lucro e o baixo custo de
produção Quem produz e vende podemos
dizer então que a regra máxima é aquele
ditado mani toque e logo aí sobre esta
ideia tudo que tenta intervir não tem o
sucesso desejado e é por isso que também
estamos a assistir a inúmeros violações
de direitos humanos pelo mundo fora e
também em causa está a sustente é do
nosso planeta e o planeta terra é de
onde vêm todos os direitos económicos
sociais e culturais que é uma das
Gerações mais importantes dos direitos
humanos e o controlo ver se recursos
muitas vezes implica com o domínio de
territórios e que tem que ver com os
direitos civis e políticos
acompanha numa viagem pelo mundo para
vermos como nós também estamos
relacionados com isto esta imagem é de
um país do Sudoeste asiático e é uma de
muitas imagens da desflorestação que
está a acontecer na Indonésia na
Tailândia por aí fora para
produzir óleo de palma o óleo de palma
está em quase todos os produtos
processados que compramos no
supermercado
chocolates biscoitos bolos cereais do
pequeno-almoço na lista dos ingredientes
são de ver que tem lá
Oi Paula
continuamos a viagem e vamos ver
aqui a imagem de uma mina de lítio esta
em áfrico das minas de lítio muitas
vezes são a céu aberto e por causa disso
destroem o ecossistema natural e o lítio
Todos nós somos capazes de ter um
bocadinho dele no nosso bolso no
telemóvel nos carros nos brinquedos em
tudo o que são baterias tem este famoso
minério tão importante o lítio até os
carros elétricos São umas uma solução
bastante mais ecológica e sustentável
que os seus pares a combustíveis fósseis
tem também este lítio mas é colocada em
causa muitos territórios onde vive gente
e que tem que mudar a sua vida e que não
beneficiam absolutamente nada da
extração destes recursos cont a viagem
vamos ver a imagem tão comum e uma
central térmica a carvão em Portugal
ainda existem existem um pouco por todo
o mundo o carvão ainda é a forma mais
barata em termos de mercado Isto é de
produzir electricidade para o nosso
consumo das nossas casas e nós não temos
como consumidores de forma de controlar
de onde é que vem a nossa energia EA
energia com que acendemos e apagamos as
luzes e utilizamos os electrodomésticos
e esta repito ainda é a forma mais
barata em termos de mercado de produzir
eletricidade continuando a nossa viagem
vamos ver
uma imagem vimos aliás uma imagem antes
e outra de um derrame de petróleo no mar
esta agora de um derrame em na região de
ogoniland fica no Delta do Níger um
acidente é uma petrolífera que aconteceu
já alguns 20 anos a esta parte e que
passou completamente despercebido para o
mundo porque as pessoas que viviam nessa
região ficaram sem o seu modo de vida o
Rios do Delta poluídos não podiam buscar
as terras que foram contaminadas com o
Cruze ficaram não se podiam trabalhar
não se pediam cultivar não era
facilmente visível porque algum tempo
depois com as chuvas a Terra ficou com a
sua cor natural mas por baixo da escura
do petróleo do Cruze e ouvir ativistas e
possui pessoas da região denunciaram a
situação e que foram acusadas pelo
governo estava a em conluio com a
empresa de petróleo e que as acusou de
terrorismo e foram condenadas à morte
graças a investigação de e
Os territórios já estão a ser limpo pela
petrolífera que causou o acidente e as
famílias das vítimas destes ativistas
foram acusados e condenados à morte por
falsas acusações de terrorismo estão já
a ser Preparadas se é que isso é de
alguma forma possível
continuamos a nossa viagem e podemos
falar de muitos outros no cais Esta é
uma imagem do Bangladesh uma criança a
trabalhar nos têxteis e vejamos nós da
nossa roupa onde é que ela é feita aqui
é uma ilustração que representa aquilo
que está a acontecer na região de
xinjiang na china onde milhões de
pessoas o Igor es que é uma minoria
étnica
chinesa que tem uma outra religião e uma
cultura diferente da cultura Ana que é
dominante a piscina e que a doutrina que
o governo quer promover e que são presas
em doutrinados obrigados a trabalhos
forçados também a produção de roupa e
que nós sem saber podemos estar a
alimentar essa economia e finalmente
podemos falar ainda de Moçambique a
extração de Areias que deixa famílias e
comunidades inteiras sem chão
literalmente podemos ainda falar da
Amazônia e da criação de gado que muitas
vezes vai vai pastar em territórios que
são reservas naturais e depois vem para
fazendas normais e legais e que Antes de
irem para abate para consumo humano é
esse o registo da fazenda que segue e
portanto nós nem desconfiamos do que
está a acontecer e aqui também falando
até do embalamento dos produtos e tão
difícil eiros ao supermercado e as
coisas a granel tudo tem plástico Pese
embora a legislação esteja avançar nesse
sentido e o plástico é Quando surge no
em meados do século 20 é um milagre uma
solução facílima de embalar de proteger
e baratíssima mas tão poluente como
vivos Qual é a solução para isto o
ativismo a escolha ética nas compras
tudo aquilo que nós podemos ter como
valores ajuda mas não resolve temos que
levar os direitos humanos a outro
patamar ao patamar do mesmo valor e do
mesmo poder e da força do dinheiro temos
que fazer com que os direitos humanos
valham dinheiro a ideia que trago aqui é
muito simples e nem sequer é muito
inovadora e talvez não seja muito
difícil de implementar uma vez que
qualquer país e qualquer e pode fazê-lo
e até mesmo ganhar dividendos em termos
fiscais de crescimento fiscal e até
proteger a sua economia de uma forma
mais ética
Imaginem que na China ou na levado a 10
não havia fábricas de têxteis com uma
mão de obra quase escrava Talvez isso
proteger-se das nossas fábricas que não
conseguem competir com isso e assim
trazemos algumas justiça a economia o
cenário mais a vossa esquerda é o
cenário atual as empresas produzem a
parte Azul os cursos por pressão a parte
de laranja os custos dos impostos e a
Cinzento naquilo que são os lucros
aquilo que proponham e que desafio é
acrescentarmos um imposto uma taxa a
todos os produtos que violem direitos
humanos isso faria com que o preço dos
produtos aumentasse
e esse competitividade porque tendo mais
caro estaria a passar para trás naquela
lógica que vimos atrás dos custos de
produção e dos lucros e do baixo preço
isso pode ser feito com essa taxa e logo
aí o cenário três os produtos que
protegessem os direitos humanos e iam
ser mais baratos mesmo que os seus
custos por via da ética e do respeito
pelo planeta e dos Direitos Humanos
fossem mais caros aqui não só uma
penalização que vemos naquele cenário
mas os estados podem ganhar mais em
termos de receita fiscal neste neste
cenário e por isso também que liam não
só finalizar mas também incentivar os
produtos que respeitam os direitos
humanos é isso que proponho neste
cenário é a baixa de impostos para
incentivar as empresas a produzirem e a
trabalharem com respeito a meta e pelos
Direitos Humanos isto muda as regras a
economia e ajuda-nos a todos a trabalhar
com com uma mudança de paradigma na
economia como implementar isto e como
princípios com que regras quem Fino que
não é preciso definir porque já está
definido a organismo das Nações Unidas
que chama aí o em Global compact e que
escreveu um dia de princípios para
negócios e direitos humanos é um guia de
princípios e portanto adesão a eles é
voluntária só que a Adesão não substitui
a questão do Vasco e do lucro e da
rentabilidade e portanto acreditamos que
este guia pode ser um bom princípio para
os estados individualmente ou juntos nas
Nações Unidas mudarem as regras e
trabalharmos todos para que a economia
faz movimentar tudo Olá seja mais
respeitadora dos seres humanos a quem
servem e do planeta que nos serve que
nos Providência tudo aquilo que são os
nossos direitos económicos sociais e
culturais fica este desafio para
mudarmos o mundo e as intermitências da
mudança e da maioria deixem de existir
Muito obrigado
E aí